Hi everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome mark Duplass.
Hello class
and was everyone today.
Um,
thanks for coming out to hear me pontificate for a little bit.
I try to be as useful as I can when I come and do this stuff.
So we're going to do like questions and answers and all that stuff afterwards.
Um,
but um,
I also like to pontificate a little bit so I'm going to do it,
but a little bit of that.
Um,
I was,
uh,
driving around the other day and there's a new show called geniuses that they
are promoting.
Um,
and I think it's meant for us to watch and be inspired by these grandiose
individuals who by sheer luck of the way they were born are just God damn
incredible and do inspiring things.
And,
um,
it really annoys me,
because they're really good at things and they're born that way.
Um,
and I find them and accessible and I find them particularly uninspiring cause it
makes me just go,
well,
I'm not ever going to be able to do that.
I'm not Einstein,
so forget it.
I'm just going to smoke some weed and play some video games.
Um,
and other than I was,
I was thinking about that.
I was like,
I,
I do know some people,
I do know some artists who,
you know,
like the Coen brothers wake up and they have a movie fully realized in their
head are right it,
they execute it,
they give it to audiences,
those audiences and moat and it's perfect.
And there are people who are in the startup realm or their tech geniuses or
whatever,
and they see a gap in society and they say,
I not only know how to conceptualize what will fill that gap,
I am confident and eloquent enough to enact that and have an IPO and just whoop
ass all over the place.
Um,
and it just occurs to me that most people I know are not like that.
And I am particularly not like that.
So if you happen to be like that,
feel free to get up and leave.
I have nothing useful to say to you today,
but if you are like me legitimately and you wake up in the morning with half
formed ideas that could be interesting,
but you don't really know how to make them good yet or how to get them there and
you have inspiration but it feels foggy and you feel not as confident as some
others who have come before you.
And you generally look in the mirror like I do and you see a good solid B minus,
you know,
like relatively good looking,
fairly well-spoken,
going to make my way in the world,
then I,
I think I can be very useful to you.
And that's what I'm going to try to do.
I've spent the last 40 years of my life trying to maximize my B minus into
something that more closely approximates a B plus and on a good day and a minus.
Um,
and the way I've done this is through a bunch of different things.
But,
um,
you know,
as I was thinking about what I was going to talk to you guys about,
a thought about a lot of these old adages that were taught to me and that were
extremely helpful to me in my life and,
and the first big one was the learn the rules before you break them.
And I always love the sound of that.
And that one proved to be pretty useless for me to be honest with you,
because I wanted to be a filmmaker.
I wanted to go out and turn into Robert Rodriguez and Richard Linklater are
Steven Soderbergh and sell my big movie at Sundance.
And so I said,
great,
I'm going to learn the rules for I break them.
It'd be a good student and to go to film school,
we don't learn how to properly cast a movie.
I'm going to buy the budgeting and scheduling software so that I'm very official
and I learned my rules and I'm going to make sure I staff up each position
correctly on sec is how can you make a good movie if you don't have everything
staffed correctly?
And I started an editing business as a backup plan just in case I didn't make
it.
I made some money.
My brother and I then got hired to do this big corporate documentary that was in
the middle of this sort of tech boom in Austin in the late nineties and we made
a bunch of money.
We made $65,000 is our salary.
So he said,
American dream is here.
We're going to go make our movie because we learned the rules.
So we set out to make a movie called Vince del Rio.
Uh,
we set a budget of $65,000 shot over four weeks,
and we did it all right.
Budgeting software,
scheduling software.
We never went over our 12 hour days.
We were the good little boys who followed all the rules.
Our crew loved us because we seem confident and we never wavered even though we
were wavering inside.
And we finished the movie and we edit it together and I put it in a test
screening in a room pretty much this size.
And we all knew it was terrible and unsalvageable and we buried the movie and
sunk into the great Duplass brothers depression of the mid two thousands for a
couple of years,
um,
where I would see profiles on the Coen brothers and these geniuses and hate
them,
uh,
and feel very far from them.
And then one day I looked at my brother,
and this is just the nature of our rhythm and our collaboration.
I said,
we're getting off the couch.
We're gonna make a movie today.
And he said,
well,
we don't have a crew,
or like a camera or the,
the budgeting software,
the scheduling software.
And I was like,
I don't care.
We're going to like figure something out.
And he was like,
well,
I'm down.
What's it about?
And then of course I was like,
well,
I don't know.
You got to figure that out.
I'm going to seven 11 to get a mini DV tape.
We're going to use mom and dad's video camera and see what happens.
So I ran a seven 11,
bought the mini DV tapes,
$3 came home.
Jay said,
I have an idea.
I had this horrifying experience where I trying to perfect the personal greeting
of my answering machine and it took me about 35 takes and I had a nervous
breakdown in the process and I was like,
that's great.
Funny,
true.
Feels like us close to home.
Don't say anymore.
We're not going to budget it,
schedule it.
Right.
We're not doing anything.
I'm going out the door.
You hold the camera like when you were 11 and when I was seven,
all I was worth doing was being able to be in it.
So I'll just be in it and you film me and let's go.
And we filmed for 20 minutes in the kitchen and I improvise this story about it.
And Jay was Kinda on his feet with our camera,
with a dead Pixel in the center and no onboard microphone whatsoever.
And I definitely didn't feel like a movie,
uh,
but it felt special to us and we cut it down to eight minutes.
And that ended up being our first movie that got into Sundance and it won all
the major short film awards that year.
And it changed everything for us because I think what we realized is we had
gotten so caught up in the proper,
an acumen of what constitutes a good professional movie that we had lost
complete touch with the cave men inside of ourselves.
And in particular the ignorant caveman who picked up the bones.
And the do I would how you would do this.
And we have found is that,
uh,
if you learn the rules too early,
and to I guess steadfastly,
um,
you will not be stupid enough to break them.
And it's very important when you're an artist to be dumb enough to have the
courage to go break those rules.
So for me,
learn the rules before you break them has really turned in to break the rules
before you learn them.
And that's a very important one for me.
A second big thing we always talk about is,
um,
in the filmmaking world and a lot in the music world,
and I guess in,
you know,
probably in the startup world too,
there's a lot of this never compromise your vision type stuff that people talk
about.
Um,
which I understand the beating heart of that and I get that.
But when Jay and I made our,
our second movie,
which was a $15,000 feature film,
um,
that was our way of making our movie our way,
not compromising our vision,
doing it the way we wanted to do it with a loan from our parents.
Um,
it turned out pretty good.
We were happy with it.
We edit it together,
we've watched it ourselves and we said,
okay,
let's fingers crossed this time,
put it in front of that group again and hope this one works.
And we did.
And about 40 to 50 people in the room all said,
this movie's pretty good.
It's working pretty well.
The first 20 minutes are a little rough.
I'm having a hard time like getting into the character as this and likability
issues as some pacing issues.
And we really felt like sticking to our guns as we were,
like,
this is our vision,
bro.
And we're all tours and we don't compromise our vision.
We like the first act of our movie,
uh,
and slowly but surely,
because we have very good friends,
they beat us down and they told us,
you can stick to your vision and being on tour and nobody's going to watch your
movie and nobody's going to like it.
And it started to creep in to us,
right?
We aren't the Coen brothers.
We aren't the geniuses who can see our movie Monday morning at 9:00 AM and exact
it perfectly.
But that doesn't mean we don't have something to offer.
That doesn't mean we can't make a relevant piece of art somehow.
So we gathered a separate meeting with those 40 people,
had them help us,
talk us through it.
We eventually rewrote the movie,
uh,
the first 15 pages of the movie.
We reshot them,
edited it,
put it back in,
gather together a new group of people and it killed.
And that was our second movie that went to Sundance.
And we sold it there and really started the kind of,
uh,
I would say the major portion of our career out of that.
And the lesson we learned was,
was really simple.
It was not,
don't ever compromise your vision.
It was quite simply always be willing to compromise your vision because you
don't know everything and that's okay.
Every film I make would be better than the last one.
If it was an empirical process of knowledge,
you need a little bit of luck and you need a lot of help.
In my opinion,
if you're a B minus,
and now I have this wonderful group of collaborators starting with the unit of
myself and my brother,
we can always lean on each other and help each other out.
Expands a little bit beyond that to a group of filmmakers that work with us,
our editors,
our producers.
That's a group of like 10 of us.
And then every single thing I make,
I put it up for a room like this in front of the smartest people I know,
filmmakers,
whomever I can get and just ask them to be as brutally honest as I,
as they can be.
And they give me their feedback and I'm able to take my B minus and muscle that
thing through the brilliant collaborater of minds of my peers into something
that every now and then it gets to like a 90 or even a 95.
And I struggled with that for awhile and it was hard on me and I thought,
it's just a bummer that I can't do this on my own cause I'm not in a tour,
I guess,
but I don't believe that anymore.
Um,
there are a couple of people who know how to do that,
but I'm not them.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
through a little bit,
Aka a lot of therapy.
I'm,
uh,
I'm getting used to it.
Um,
third adage I always heard,
um,
was this,
this old saying,
the cavalry isn't coming,
which is meant to exemplify for you.
You are either in the battlefield and losing and looking for a bailout or as
often as the case for outlier artists,
inventors,
whatnot.
You haven't even gotten to the battlefield yet and you are looking for someone
to come,
pluck you and save you and mentor you and assure you to success.
But the truth is the cavalry isn't coming.
Now,
this is one that I have actually found to be mostly true.
I'm starting with our $3 short film that we made in our kitchen.
We went to Sundance,
we got agents there and our agents called us to a meeting and they said,
congratulations,
you worked so hard to get to this point.
We got you.
Now the cavalry has here.
We're going to take your next script and package it in the studio system with
some mid level TV stars and we're going to get you $1 million to go make your
movie.
And we said,
awesome.
That sounds so exciting.
We waited for six months a year.
Nothing happened.
Cavalry didn't come,
but we know how to make cheap movies.
So he said,
okay,
why don't we write like a movie that we can make for like $50,000 and here we
invented our available school materials of filmmaking,
which we call,
which is right for what you have at your disposal.
Um,
you know,
and at that time we wrote the puffy chair.
It was,
I have an apartment,
I have a van,
my girlfriend,
Katie's apartment,
small town where she grew up,
where people will be nice to us and let us shoot for free.
And we were able to make that movie for $15,000.
Our next movie bag had was we'll rent two cabins in the woods,
we'll shoot.
And one of them will stay in both of them over the course of three weeks.
And with a cast and crew at 1215 people,
we can make a $50,000 movie that probably won't lose money and keep moving
forward while we continue to wait for the cavalry to come through our agents.
We went to Sundance with that movie and the movie sold for half a million
dollars.
And we said,
Oh shit,
okay,
wait a second.
Because now we might be making close to the kinds of money we would have made if
we had made that million dollar movie in the studio system doing it our own way
and,
and financing it.
Granted,
we were not genius startup mentalities who are thinking ownership is the key
because society is headed towards vertical integration and we were just like,
nobody will do anything for us.
So we're going to take profits for profit share and make a movie.
Um,
and that came in thinking again that that ignorance and slight idiocy was good
for us.
Um,
so after bag had sold,
our agents called us in and they said,
congratulations guys,
you've worked so hard up to this point,
but now we got you with two sales out of Sundance.
We are sure to go out and get you a studio movie and get it made.
And we said,
great.
So we waited for a little while and it didn't happen.
And then we had some friends who worked at a,
I worked at Fox searchlight and they had said they wanted to make a movie with
us.
And we said,
okay,
well we'll think about it.
And actually they did come around and they gave us a $7 million to make a
relationship movie with John C.
Reilly,
Jonah hill and Marissa Tomi called Cyrus.
And we were like,
well this is the dream.
This is everything we've been waiting for.
And it almost killed us because they didn't actually pay us very well.
They tortured us quite a bit throughout the film making process in terms of what
they needed to make it a marketable product.
Uh,
and by the time we were done,
we made the movie we wanted to make,
which was great,
but we realized if we do this three or four more times,
we will be burned out and retired by the time we hit 40.
Um,
interestingly enough,
while this was happening,
we had started to turn into producers randomly.
The way it started was our friends would come to us and say,
you guys sold some Sundance movies.
Do you have any money?
And we were like,
sure,
you know,
here's $5,000 to go make your movie.
We never saw that as becoming producers,
but that's what we were doing.
We were giving them money,
helping them with their cuts,
advising them,
and those movies started selling well and making money.
And after we made Cyrus,
our agents came to us and said,
congratulations guys,
you've worked so hard.
We're going to go get you a mega studio deal.
And overall the all to make the kinds of movies you want to make.
And it was the dream.
It really was.
And we started thinking about what that could mean to us.
And then we got really nauseous and sick to our stomachs because we had been
waiting our whole lives for the cavalry to come get us.
And finally the cavalry was here and we were looking at in the face and we
realized we don't need the cavalry.
And I think we don't want the cavalry because after building little movies,
$3 short films,
$15,000 features $50,000 feature,
we realized not only were we able to make them in the collaborative process that
we wanted to make them,
we were actually making them in a financially sustainable way and a startup
model.
And it was better than working for the cavalry.
And we had this great realization of,
Oh my God,
maybe you don't need the cavalry if you are the cavalry.
And since that day we have kind of stayed away from taking anybody else's money.
And I've continually just rolled over the profits from everything we make
further into the making of our movies.
And it's been the best thing that's happened to us.
And,
and we try to give this advice to people not in a way that says we knew exactly
what we were doing from the beginning.
We really stumbled into it because we had no other option and the people that I
meet and that I talked to feel that way.
They feel like I have all this magic inside of me and I have no connections and
I don't know how to get this out and I don't have the skill sets.
Um,
and our general advice is just keep making this stuff on your own and eventually
it will snowball into a machine that is,
that is unstoppable for you and you will find yourself as strange as it sounds.
And it's strange as it feels to me to this day to stand up here and a blazer and
speak to you as if I am in some sort of position of authority or knowledge that
is useful and you will,
and people will look at you and write articles about you.
And the best part is they're going to say you're a genius and you will know deep
inside that you are just a B minus in genius clothing.
But you were smart enough to figure out how to make it work for you and your
victory and your success will be that much sweeter for it.
So thank you for listening.
That's my pontification
portion.
I'd love to go back to something you said about half formed ideas.
How do you decide which ones you want to sort of evolved into?
A fully formed idea is like how far down that pathway do you go before you go?
Hmm.
We should probably focus on something else.
Yeah,
it's an interesting thing.
I mean,
uh,
my brother and I who,
you know,
obviously our relationship is incredibly complex and a deep collaboration.
Um,
and it's a wonderful and terrible thing.
we talk a lot about what we are able to do with building blocks with each other
because we do share the same creative brain most of the time.
But every now and then you get an idea that is hard to explain,
but it's a feeling based thing.
Uh,
and you cannot verbalize it well.
And if you don't verbalize it correctly,
you will watch the eyes of the person you're pitching it to and they won't be
excited and it'll start to kill your own magic.
So what I try to do in the early stages before I can get it together in my
mouth,
I try to hold it in the dream scape stage.
And it's a very important incubating stage for creative ideas in my opinion.
Um,
and I've,
uh,
I've lost a lot of them cause I took them out before they were ready to be
birthed.
Um,
and,
and then once you've kind of got it down to a place where you're like,
I know what this is and I can verbalize it,
then I really,
then I go to Jay and all my trusted collaborators and we start hammering it and
trying to build the thing up.
And if you find yourself truly exhausted after about two hours of talking about,
it usually means you're trying too hard to make something live that can't live.
In my experience.
The ones that are ready to go,
they start to come very quickly and they will be rough hewn,
but they will,
they will make themselves known a little bit more quickly.
So the,
the long and the short of it for me is,
you know,
that whole Bill Joel thing,
I never want to work that hard.
Like if you,
if you are sweating a lot,
um,
there's such a thing as too much elbow grease and you kind of let it go.
And for me,
they always up going back into the pool,
getting caught up in the chlorine and they come back to me a couple of years
later and something else.
So
I suppose it's the same sort of mentality is like there's only so much you can
Polish a Turd.
Not that they're turning out,
but like at a certain point in coma,
it just hurts.
Not at all.
Um,
yes,
I,
I agree.
How do you personally define success?
Ooh,
that's a,
that's a hard question.
I mean,
uh,
it's,
it's hard to define.
For me it's,
it's an ever changing thing.
My brother and I talk about,
uh,
recalibrating the mountains that we like to climb.
And I think that when I was younger,
the idea that I might one day get a feature film into Sundance and sit in that
audience.
And watch it play,
no matter what happened was as far as I could dream of going.
That happened when I was 28 and happened way earlier than I thought it was going
to happen.
And I cried in the movie theater when it happened and it was beautiful.
And the next day I was super depressed a because,
uh,
I had killed my God,
that was my God I was chasing and B,
it didn't make me happy and I started to realize,
Oh shit,
if you get to the top of the mountain,
you've been climbing,
it's not definitely going to make you happy.
I'm still,
that's just an intellectual concept.
So I still keep making new mountain's for myself and Oh if I get there,
it's going to be really awesome.
I want to get there and it's given me a really awesome,
you know,
and uh,
this is totally a midlife crisis.
He stuff cause I just turned 40.
Um,
but now it's,
it's definitely the sort of realization that there's really nothing else I'm
going to do career wise that's going to make like a big splash for me,
you know?
Um,
I have enough money to eat and put my kids through school and own a home.
That's it.
I'm good.
And I have the creative freedom to make the projects I want.
That's it.
I'm good.
So now it's really all about collaborating with my favorite people on the planet
and trying to make the process of making stuff as important as the product,
which when I was in my twenties I was really willing to destroy myself in the
process and hurt badly to get a good product.
Now I'm trying to like get some joy in the process too so I can live long.
And in terms of,
because you do have your hands in so many different pies and then projects,
um,
how,
how do you like manage your time with that?
Because it sounds like,
you know,
you're focusing on the things you really want to,
but at the same time you're also producing an exec producing and writing and
then starting at other people think,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a couple of things.
Um,
you know,
I don't have a social life.
I've given that up.
I have my marriage,
I have my kids,
I have my work life,
and then I read books.
That's really all that I do.
Um,
I don't even really watch movies anymore.
and so that's something that keeps things efficient.
I don't believe in working 12 hour crazy days.
Um,
sometimes you have to do that when you're on set according to union rules and
such.
But I really believe in the eight hour day,
I like working nine to five.
I like being,
uh,
for dinner with my kids and like playing board games with my kids.
It's like that is I think very important to refuel you for your creativity,
but also lead a well balanced life.
Um,
so the other answer is I'm,
I'm pretty ruthlessly efficient with my time.
You know,
I don't get on conference calls,
um,
if I don't have to be there.
I'm very good at delegating authority because it comes from a place of the
inherent belief that I just don't know best that I only know best collectively
with my people to back me up.
So I'm totally willing to pass things off unless I know for sure I'm the perfect
person to do it.
If I don't know that,
pass it off,
give it to somebody else.
That's just as good of a chance that they'll do better with it.
I really believe now,
you know,
I made a movie called Blue Jay that I should have directed according to
everybody.
Cause I wrote it,
I started it,
I produced it.
Why not just direct it?
Right.
Well my thing was like,
well then don't have to sit in the edit room for three more months after it's
done.
I'd have to location scout and be there upfront.
Why don't know a hire like a 30 year olds,
less experienced but super inspired and hungry kid to do it.
Who,
what he lacks in experience.
He will beat me out and dedication and time spent.
So it's,
it's things like that that kind of helped me be a,
be a human being.
Um,
and then,
you know,
the last thing is,
um,
I don't take any meetings.
General meetings are a huge thing in this town,
in this crazy industry.
And I know they happen in other industry too.
Man.
Let's meet up.
Let's see if it was like a way we can like collaborate on something together.
45 minutes to drive there.
Five minutes waiting in the office.
25 minutes of bullshit talk.
Yeah,
we're going to work together forever.
Another 30 minutes driving home,
two hours gone.
And you could have written 10 great pages of a script in those two hours that
you talked about it.
So I don't take any general meetings and something I've really had to do.
It's like kind of broke my heart.
But like I,
I really like being a mentor in this industry as much as I can.
But now I've gotten to the place where I get like probably 10 emails a day from
young filmmakers saying,
can I take you out for lunch?
Can I take you to coffee and pick your brain?
And,
and I used to love to do that,
but I just can't do that and stay productive.
So now what I say,
which is so hard,
I just say,
you know,
I,
I could lie to you and say,
yeah,
maybe we'll do it in six months.
But the truth is if in six months I do get time,
I'm going to use that time for my kids or to maybe exercise or something.
So I'm never going to be able to meet with you and I don't want you to waste
your time trying to get me to meet with you and save you.
Here's what you should do.
Ask me your five most important questions right now.
I'll answer them on email.
Here's a speech that I gave at south by southwest and it gives you specific
details of how to make a movie.
And that's kind of why I do talks like this.
I can centralize it and then go with God and,
and good luck.
So it's a little bit of just like,
you know,
dialing in and like,
I mean,
I joked before,
but I have a fantastic relationship with my therapist that thank God my
director's guild insurance pays for and I meet with her twice a week and we like
hard core architecture,
my life.
It's not like feelings and stuff in there.
I bring her like my three main issues.
I'm like,
I've got a time management issue here.
One of my staff members is not great here.
I want to do these two things.
I've got to figure out which one because I know I can only do one.
And she's way smarter than me and more emotionally evolved and she works it out
with me.
And that's uh,
that's been a huge help to me.
So if you got health insurance,
fine,
like a super smart,
organized therapists and they will rock your fucking world's yeah,
sure.
Tangible advice.
Yeah.
Oh No,
it's real dude.
And then every now and then you think you're going there to get organized advice
and you just ended up crying about something else and the,
and they're,
they're right there for you.
So that's great.
That's,
it's an excellent resource.
Yeah.
It's all about utilizing what resources.
Um,
uh,
I'd love to talk more about sort of developing community because you already
have this built in like default committee.
You,
your brother,
like that's from the start,
you know,
settled with a collaborator.
Um,
but sort of growing that community over the years,
like,
do you find yourself working with mostly the same?
I,
I've seen you work with a lot of the same people over the years,
but what does,
what does it sort of,
when,
what does it like when you bring somebody new into that collaborative?
Yeah.
Yes.
There's a couple of things about the collaborations that I truly believe in.
Obviously I have my brother and,
and the wonderful and terrible nature of everything that we are together.
Um,
and,
and then there is w uh,
the thing that Jay and I call having affairs on each other,
you know,
which is,
it's really important for j to be able to go beyond transparent and be whoever
he wants to be in front of them and not have me standing right behind him who
knows everything about him.
Silently judging him for being a little bit different for who he is today.
He gets to be the free spirited j of whatever the fuck he wants to be in that
moment.
And he gets to collaborate with someone in a new way who appreciates him in a
new way and it rejuvenates him.
Likewise,
I get to go off either as an actor or maybe as a producer like I did with with
Blue Jay,
with Sarah Paulson and develop these new emotional relationships.
So I think it's very healthy.
They're little retreats that,
that keep you going if you have a main collaborative marriage.
Um,
likewise,
um,
when we are hiring new collaborators or new people to work with,
I found this out on accident,
but I really believe in it now.
Um,
I hire strictly on thought process and personality style.
skillset is not even anything I consider.
In fact,
I find hiring an experienced producer can be a negative because the first thing
they do is I've got my budgeting software,
am I scheduling software?
And we're just like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
You know,
hiring the most brilliant inspired and nice loving,
evolved people that I can,
you can teach them all the other stuff in a week.
You can't teach any of that other stuff.
So it's not really anything new.
But,
um,
I find that often in the film business,
people really hire for credits.
Um,
and I don't believe in that.
And it,
most importantly,
I like to work with people who are young and excited and are willing to give me
their best and are willing to take their errors because of their lack of
experience because it made up for in dedication and enthusiasm.
So many times you're on a film shoot,
put together a million dollar movie and they're like,
dude,
I think I can get,
um,
you know,
Bradford young to be RDP for this.
And I'm like,
if you get Bradford young by chance to work at one 50th of his rate,
he's going to be so goddamn miserable on this movie and he's going to want
everything to go his way because he's working at a reduced rate.
Don't do that to yourself higher.
The 26 year old kid who shot up beautiful short and is ready for his step up and
we'll give you the world for it.
How do,
how do you sort of source these people,
not sorts of,
I'm,
I assume some come to you summer through your network,
but like how do you discover or be put in touch with like this sort of,
yeah,
I mean a lot,
some of it is like,
I have a relationship with Sundance and I'm like,
hey guys,
send me the to 10 really incredible short films that you saw this year.
You know,
and,
and uh,
same thing with documentary film makers.
Um,
some of it is,
you know,
we really believe in kind of promoting from within.
So some people start with us as assistance and they grow up and our companies
kind of weird.
There's not a lot of people there.
So technically my assistant who's like scheduling me is also the lead producer
of creep to like,
you know,
everybody's doing lots of different things.
Um,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
I don't have a good answer for how we find them.
It's definitely not like,
we definitely don't do interviews or anything.
Yeah,
for sure.
But just like,
what are,
I guess if there were like stand out moments of like,
Hey,
this is actually how we got like the producer of creepy.
Yeah.
We met up at Sundance is a perfect
Alix layman who directed Bluejay for me was one of the shooters on the league
that I was on for years and it was the land of sarcastic Dick Jokes.
And Alex and I would end up talking about like documentaries by the craft
service table by ourselves and found that we had a little thing there and,
and you know,
I was like,
oh,
I need a director who can shoot really well and who's really smart and sensitive
and,
and who I'm close with and you know,
has just had a feeling about him and took a chance.
You know,
I really like,
I really like taking chances on young people for all the reasons we've talked
about.
Um,
going back to blue Jay or continuing with Blue Jay Dee,
do you find it challenging to be in roles that you've written or is it almost
easier because it's obviously there's a natural connection?
I personally feel like I am at my best as a performer when it's something that I
have written for a number of reasons.
One,
I feel empowered to trash the dialogue without feeling bad about what I'm doing
to the writer so I can improvise in the moment.
Obviously I have a deeper of the character because I've been living with it for
a long time.
Um,
and all false modesty aside and everything.
I'm never,
I'm not the kind of actor like,
you know,
for me like Oscar Isaac or,
or you know,
Sarah Paulson who you look at them and you see the ocean in their eyes and they
don't have to say anything and they just emote and they are just unbelievably
magnetic.
You know,
I really believe I'm more of the B minus version of that.
But what makes me really good and relevant is I know how to control a narrative
from inside of a scene.
I know how to make the person across from me look really,
really good and serve them up the things that are going to make them score in
the moment.
So I'm kind of,
when I'm puppeteering a little bit,
kind of producing,
directing,
writing,
acting from inside the scene,
which is how I came up doing stuff because it was just me and Jay,
you know,
um,
that,
that is a skill set that I have just randomly,
I think,
I think I've really perfected that thing.
I'm talking about sort of digital distribution.
Yeah.
It's like the hot term paper.
I feel like it has enabled you and men,
it's like a ton of other people that yeah.
Can you doing these projects that,
you know,
it's,
you're able to instill more of yourself in it.
Yeah.
Um,
sort of you guys embrace that from the start I feel like.
Yeah.
And it wasn't,
again,
you know,
it wasn't a top down philosophy.
I didn't understand this business when I started.
I was a musician first before I was a filmmaker and I was so bummed that I was
10 years too late to the digital reservoir,
a revolution in music.
You know,
you could make a really great computer at home,
sorry,
you could make a really great record on your computer at home in like 1995.
Um,
and I was starting to make records and like 2002 and the market was flooded and
nobody cared about what I had to say and stuff I was making was okay.
And I would just,
I didn't get there.
Um,
in 2005 when I started really turning my attention towards filmmaking,
that's when the technology hit.
So I literally was that lucky asshole who was in the perfect place at the
perfect time.
I really believe like my first movie,
the Puffy Chair,
it's a good movie.
It's got a big heart.
It's got some smarts in it.
I believe if I submit that movie to Sundance today,
it does not get in in 2005.
There weren't that many of us and I was there and I was luckily able to ride
that wave and the technology is now getting not only cheaper and cheaper to make
stuff,
but obviously with things like Netflix and iTunes.
Um,
I realized what a perfect platform that is for the kind of art I make.
And not to keep beating a dead horse here,
but um,
when you watch a movie on Netflix,
I think you essentially perceive it as watching it for free because either you
are paying for your service up front and it's hidden in the back of your mind
through your auto bill,
a credit card,
or you're stealing your dad's password like I am.
Which is so weird that I still do that.
I haven't,
oh,
I have an overall deal at Netflix and an overall deal at HBO.
And I'm using my dad's password
both places.
So you're,
you're like played huge.
It's a bunch of your stuff.
Does he like,
oh,
he's on the count and that they account again,
it works out good
cause he doesn't know what good stuff to put on.
So he gets my curation for free and he pays the big bucks for it.
Um,
it's really embarrassing.
it's economic
and economic.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
so yeah.
So for me,
I think it's really crucial to a movie.
I keep using blue Jay,
but it's the last one I made.
It's a small black and white relationship movie with me and Sarah Paulson.
It's a curiosity factor movie in my opinion.
If I'm objective looking at Blue Jay and I hadn't made it,
I'm not paying $15 to see that in the movie theater.
Some people will,
the rabid fans,
but probably not.
Uh,
more people will pay six 99 to rent it on iTunes,
but everybody will watch it on Netflix and we release it globally and quietly,
millions and millions of people have watched blue Jay to a comparative box
office number over $100 million of my viewers.
Now I don't see that money because they're free clicks.
But I wouldn't have gotten a 20th of those viewers if I didn't have Netflix
because they are not going to come and pay in the movie theater.
And you know,
sometimes I feel like that's a little bit of a defeatist bottom feeder ideology.
But most of the time I feel like thank God I have a place where all these people
will come see my movies.
Who am I to be picky as an independent filmmaker?
You know?
So I to your first question and extremely grateful for the digital platforms
that are allowing people to watch movies for free and take little risks on them.
And what I try to do is say,
you click on my movie,
I want to be the one that takes you all the way through it because ideally I
made you a really,
really good movie.
Would you say when it comes to things like working with Hbo,
um,
whether it's a little more,
well I don't know,
is there,
is there more sort of high touch?
Like are they more involved in it or are they just like,
hey,
go forth and do,
do your thing.
Everything is tricky.
Uh,
with all of my deals,
most of the deals I,
that I try to make,
and I'll try not to get too like Samantha about this,
but most of the deals I try to make our,
our,
our deals that say,
listen,
I'm making this for a fraction of the price of your other things that you make.
So just kind of let us do our thing.
And uh,
if you fall in love with it through all your promotional dollars at it and it's
going to be great.
And if you happen to just kind of like it and just let it sit on your service
and people will find it long term,
I'm okay with that.
You know?
I don't try to beat the shit out of my networks on that front.
Yeah,
no,
it just in terms of like what,
what's,
what would you say is the most absurd thing that they've sort of glommed on to
and that you were most surprised then?
I mean,
HBO honestly is Pretty Great.
You know,
like we were bummed when they cancelled togetherness,
but I understand that the landscape is changing and they have different
objectives that they need to achieve.
Netflix is a place where it's a fifth store.
Everything's there.
You got to go sift through it.
Hbo needs to be a place that says,
I'm curating for you so that everything you click is good and that's why they're
trying to get people to pay a little bit extra for that price so they have to be
careful and they spend a little more money.
I haven't gotten those like crazy studio notes for a long time.
My first studio movie,
I was shocked at the stuff that they wanted me to do.
I was telling the story of a depressed 40 year old man and who lived in a shitty
apartment because he had no money and they looked at the dailies and they were
like,
it's just so down and Brown.
And I was like,
yeah,
cause he's depressed and he doesn't have any money.
And then they asked me if I'd be willing to put some colorful throw pillows and
the scene and reshoot the scene after I've just earned John Riley's trusts,
the first movie star I've ever worked for and I'm 29 years old.
Um,
they want me to go tell him we have to re shoot the scene because even though
his performance was impeccable,
we'd like to have some throw pillows in there.
And I'm a very amenable person.
I've been to therapy,
I know how to validate,
I know how to communicate well.
And I did all of that stuff leading up to that point.
And they perceive that as weakness and they started trampling all over us.
But when they asked me for the throw pillows,
they pulled up a fucking van outside of set after a 12 hour shoot day and made
us sit in the van and asked us for throw pillows and I lost my shit.
And I started screaming.
And from that minute to them in the studio world,
that meant,
oh,
he has vision,
good to know.
And they started leaving me alone
and I really,
it almost killed me.
And I was like,
I cannot function inside of a world where in order to be taken seriously and
taken out my word,
I have to be a raging dickhead
about throw pillows about brokers.
Yeah.
And I won't,
I won't do it.
That's probably a good thing.
Generally speaking.
Yeah.
Uh,
we'll take audience questions in a minute,
but I just want to ask a few quick questions.
Of course,
because of these evolved clearly been super quick.
Um,
uh,
what,
so what inspires you?
Like where do you draw your inspiration from?
Like,
um,
question,
I don't seek it.
You know,
I don't go and say like,
oh,
I need this because I need to feel inspired.
Uh,
I really like reading books.
Um,
and I,
uh,
like exercising a lot.
That helps me kind of get into a dream space.
And music is a big thing for me,
but mostly,
um,
I kind of am an extremely nostalgic person for whatever reason.
That's just the way that I am.
Um,
and,
and the war,
I lean into that and my sense of weird longing in the world,
uh,
for things that were or aren't or could be.
And if I do that in a way that has a sense of humor about itself and pokes fun
at,
um,
that seems to be my special sauce or whatever you want to call,
it seems to be the thing that people connect to.
Um,
and,
and resonates and it's where I'm really comfortable.
So,
um,
I tend to kind of live in that space for whatever reason.
What's one of the things that you struggle with that you maybe in the beginning
of your career not to still be struggling with now?
Well,
that's a really good question.
Um,
I think I thought it was going to get,
um,
progressively easier to make good pieces of art.
Um,
I thought I was going to get a lot more skilled at the process and that would
directly translate to better products more quickly and with less tension and
struggle.
And that has not been the case.
Um,
I find that every time I show up to make something,
I feel confused and I feel lost.
And I have good tricks that I've learned throughout the way,
but,
but it's,
um,
the elusiveness of trying to make an inspired an original piece of art remains
enormous for me.
Um,
and it makes sense because you said if it was a learning process,
everything you made would get better than the last,
but you got to get lucky.
You gotta be in the right place.
And that weird,
um,
phantom alchemy of what makes something good is just as far from my reach as it
was when I started
living or dead.
Who is someone you'd love to collaborate with that you haven't already?
Um,
and that's a really great question.
I mean,
the first instinct I had was I love my people.
Like I'm not looking for anybody else.
I've got trust and I've got,
um,
like,
you know,
it sounds stupid,
but like I can laugh and cry with all the people I work with and that takes a
little time to like build that up,
you know?
Um,
so yeah,
I'm not really,
I'm not really craving anything.
I'm kind of good where I'm at.
I think that's probably a good thing.
Yeah.
Um,
you've,
you've given us some great advice today,
so what's one of the best pieces of advice that you've been given?
Mm,
Jay and I talked about this a lot and we realize that we never had a mentor.
Um,
and I think part of it is because we've been very insular with our energy.
Part of it is we tried to do a career where there was no one around us who had
done this career to help us.
Um,
but we've never ever had anybody come to us and say,
let me give you a hand with this,
or you should try this.
And,
and I think it's been great for us.
It was really a struggle.
Um,
but it,
it,
it made us ultimately extremely resourceful.
Um,
and whenever I overcome an obstacle,
now I don't really look around for something to kind of a calendar,
show me what to do.
I just kind of grab the nearest people around me and my group of collaborators
and call a meeting and then we just attack it.
Um,
and it was hard,
you know,
like spend a lot of time,
like super anxious and depressed through my twenties and all that stuff.
It's scared I wasn't gonna be able to make anything decent.
Um,
but,
um,
I guess I'm glad for it now.
Cool.
Yeah.
Anyone wants to ask a question?
Mark?
Hello?
I am super interested in sibling development teams and I'm curious,
looking back if there's any rhyme or reason to why you and your brother teamed
up basically as a father of four siblings,
it's manipulate them in any way.
Yes,
a great,
great question.
Um,
I'll try to be my parents right now and tell you what they did to us and if
there's anything useful.
Um,
I don't have a ton of nuggets here.
one thing is that,
um,
we were,
uh,
thoroughly,
left to our own devices and we had a very uncurated childhood.
We were thrown together and we had to figure out how to do things ourselves.
Uh,
so it was never here's a piano and go ahead and learn it.
We had to beg them to buy us a $12 Casio so that we could learn it.
Um,
and for whatever reason it fostered us and in,
in a,
in a voracious tenacity with each other,
uh,
because we feel,
we felt like,
you know,
I mean,
they look,
our parents are great and they loved this,
but Jay was my tribe in terms of,
you know,
what I needed.
So with a distinct lack of leadership at the top,
we were like super tight together.
Um,
they did not intervene and our fights and they let us work it out.
they were able to do that because Jay,
my older brother is just super sweet and didn't beat the shit out of me.
So the conflicts were never physically dangerous.
They were always emotional.
Um,
and so they just let us do our thing.
and the only thing that I think they didn't curate but happened,
which was good,
is that every now and then when we were fighting,
they would punish us just one level,
two unjustly.
Um,
and that would make us go to our rooms and join forces against the greater evil
of them and get rid of all the conflict between us.
And I think that might've been one of the more effective ones.
So there's a little something going on,
Hammer them times too,
and be willing to sacrifice yourself in that and it might make them join against
you because now you're the depth,
common threat.
Okay.
Thank you.
Hi.
Uh,
I wanted to know what kind of budgets off to the software you're using.
Yes,
it's a very good question.
I'm not going to tell you,
you know,
um,
I think the $3 short stories are really,
or the story about the $3 short is a really inspiring,
and I wanted to know what if I told you you had today,
this afternoon free,
what would you make?
Um,
I'm doing,
I do have this afternoon free.
Uh,
so here's what's coming up.
I'm going to leave here,
I'm going to drive home as soon as I can.
Um,
I'm going to have dinner with my kids at five o'clock and I want to try to
exercise at four 30.
So that means between about two 15 and four 30,
I have some time about an hour that I got to watch cuts for room one oh four on
my new show,
but I'll get about an hour to like do something with.
Um,
and what I'm doing right now is I am writing a novel and I don't know what it's
about.
Um,
but I'm writing in 300 word chunks and there's an old guy named Norman and he's
talking through me right now and,
and I specifically have a completely unstructured and out to sea so that I feel
kind of 13 or 14.
Again,
just picking up a guitar for the first time and I don't know what I'm doing.
Does that intense learning curve when you first learn something that's so
exciting?
It makes you feel young.
And then we get good at our craft and we,
and we get steadfast and you lose a little bit of that child like excitement.
So for me it's very important to like constantly pick up new things and like get
that sense of fumbling through it.
And I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
And so fiction writing is that for me right now.
Cool.
Thanks.
Yeah.
And budget software is a Microsoft word document,
gas colon,
$500.
The Home Depot lights $350 up front return within 30 days,
$350 back.
Um,
hi,
big fan.
By the way,
as a writer performer,
I started to find myself in a pitch rooms around town and uh,
I've noticed that every time I try and talk about wanting to do something that's
relationship based,
like this is John or blue Jay or puffy chair.
Um,
they go,
that's awesome.
So what's your hook?
And it makes it really tough.
I think when you sit there and you can make things up and smile,
but when you leave,
you end up in a place where it's like just how do you make something like that?
How do you get these people to be,
and I guess the answer might be you don't,
but how do you kind of get these people to hear that?
Yeah,
the the the,
the tough answer is you don't,
but the hopeful answer is the more successful and the more stuff you have made,
the less you need a hook.
So basically at this point,
Paul Thomas Anderson can walk into a room and be like,
the movie's called spoon.
And they say,
what's it about?
And he says,
don't worry about it.
And they say,
okay,
here's your money.
I'm not there.
But I can walk in and say,
I'm going to make a movie called spoon.
It's about me and Sarah Paulson.
It's black and white and it's relationship oriented.
I don't know.
It's not going to smash,
but you're going to get my brand to collaborate with.
You're going to get a really well reviewed movie to make you look cool.
Next to your Adam Sandler movie that makes you kind of not look that cool.
Um,
and so like overpaying me a little bit for this,
I'll make sure it's good and you don't have to bother with me and I get to do
that there.
Unfortunately you're stuck here right now where they're asking you for your
hook.
So what you need to do is make the hook list thing that you want to make on your
own a couple of times so that it's film festival.
Now it's a a Sundance film festival and now you've sold one,
sold it whenever you gave it to a company who distributed for free on Itunes,
but you got it out there and then you have that sample and then you have that
thing that says,
well,
so what?
What's your hook?
And you say,
no,
no.
It specifically,
it's actually not about a hook.
The Hook would distract from just like the actual meat of the hamburger.
What I'm trying to do here,
we don't want to put all this lettuce over it,
watch this,
and I'll show you how it works.
And then you got a little more power.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Hello.
I'm a really big fan of your work and how it balances the,
the drama aspects with,
uh,
you know,
sort of a lighthearted tone.
Thank you.
Um,
but I was wondering,
uh,
you talked a lot about anxiety and depression.
Um,
do you find that that actually helps inspire you when trying to create these
dramatic situation?
Um,
I mean,
it's a part of me and it's been a part of me my whole life.
Um,
and I don't really make a secret out of it.
I take medication now to help curb that so I can be a functional dad,
husband,
head of companies,
all that stuff.
Um,
but I don't take so much so that I'm a Zombie.
So it's there and I feel it.
Um,
and you know what I would say is what it's less about the anxiety and the
depression itself that has helped me to get there.
In terms of that old argument of,
do you need to be sad to make,
uh,
a great stuff?
I don't believe that.
Um,
do you need to be in pain to make great stuff?
I don't believe that.
But what has come out of that is my ability to accept it within myself,
go to therapy,
figure it out,
get a handle on it,
and then be able to laugh at the sides of it that are kind of funny and
interesting that has what's been made for me,
at least my art unique.
You know,
like some people are able to make great art out of other things that's just like
unilaterally serious or unilaterally hilarious.
My particular brand is that.
And so,
you know,
I can't speak to exactly what's going on with you,
but what I'm hearing from you is like,
um,
how is that going to be either a hindrance or a help to the kind of stuff I want
to be.
And what I always say to that is the last conversation you had with someone you
are close with,
whether it was a loved one or a sibling or a friend or one of your parents and
you were one of you is either crying and admitting something or giggling
uncontrollably about something.
That was,
it felt extremely personal and specific and that only the two of you can
understand it and that felt kind of insider [inaudible] that's the stuff that
you uniquely have to offer.
And it took me a long time to figure that out cause I was just like,
well that's not film worth it cause that's just a part of my B minus boring
middleclass life.
But if you can see the big humanity and that stuff,
you are the only person who can tell that kind of story.
So I kind of direct people to look towards that little space.
Oh thank you.
Yeah.
Hi.
Um,
what's the book you're reading now and what's your favorite book?
Ooh,
that's really tough.
Okay.
The book,
uh,
I'm reading now is Neil Gaiman's,
American gods.
I have for the first time kind of really dug into,
I guess speculative fiction and science fiction.
I've always been like a relationship,
you person and I kind of burned through a lot of those books and now I'm like,
there's this whole world that I explore that you know of,
of the science fiction world.
I haven't even seen like the godfather of science fiction yet,
you know,
so I'm just getting into it and being brought into it by people who are sending
me read lefthanded darkness.
He read,
you know,
and I'm like,
it's so exciting.
So that's cool for me.
And I'm really interested in telling stories that,
um,
you know,
can do ideally the very personal,
uh,
emotional relationship thing that I do and then maybe bring that into the sort
of speculative and Saifai world.
This would be cool.
Um,
I have two favorite books I have to differentiate them.
One is,
um,
favorite reading experience,
which is not my favorite book,
but the most a book has ever affected me.
And it was when I was 18 and I read a prayer for Owen meany by John Irving.
And,
and I think I read that book now and I'd probably like see the machinations,
and it might be a little cheesy,
but like when you're 18 and about to face the world and the way that that felt
similarly as super embarrassing,
but the grow,
the ultimate movie experience I've ever had is when I was 19.
And watch titanic for the same reason.
And I don't love the movie now,
but I just had an experience.
And then I guess,
you know,
I took me,
took me four tries to do it,
but I got through infinite jest last year and that has just,
that just really knocked me out.
And that for those who have read it or not,
there's a character in there named Don Gately and how he has presented and the
level of empathy and love and specialists in him.
It was just like beyond for me.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Hi.
Um,
I,
I was thinking about what you were saying earlier,
how,
you know,
initially you,
you work with your brother,
right?
You had a builtin team to start with and now you're at the point where you can
select for people you work with based on personality and based on,
you know,
who you're comfortable delegating things too.
And I'm curious,
when you were just starting out,
um,
how did you end up falling in or choosing the people you worked with and what
might you have done differently when you're starting to pick people to either
work with or give you feedback?
That's a really great question.
Um,
and,
uh,
when I was first starting out,
I was under the impression that I needed to grab people with the biggest credits
and the most experience possible cause I was clamoring for a mentor and someone
to lift me up,
which is I think what I get a lot of when people email me and I meet them at a
festival and they say,
Oh my God,
you know,
will you read my script and will you produce for me?
You know,
and I really wanted that person to come help and save me.
And,
and what I didn't get for a long time is that that's not their job.
Um,
I needed to figure out who I was,
um,
and make my own way.
Um,
and I ended up doing that just because I was forced to hundred and having the
other options.
But if I could go back to myself now,
I would say really embraces,
don't see this as a,
um,
well this is your only option.
So just do it.
And don't try to get your script to Richard Linklater who doesn't give a shit
about what you have to say right now cause he's busy with his own stuff.
Find the people at your level who would be honored and excited to be with you.
Um,
and who you click with.
Again,
from a personality standpoint,
from a smarts level,
from an emotional standpoint,
um,
and look,
look on the ground near you.
Um,
or even,
you know,
someone who doesn't even have as much experience as you and,
and reach below and,
and,
and bring them with you.
Um,
and I want,
I kind of figured that out once we started working with,
I would say,
who is our main third collaborator?
J Doobie.
Just weird.
Everybody thinks it's a fake name we've made up cause it sounds like Jay's name.
And also both of his names stand for marijuana.
Um,
and I'm just like,
we wouldn't make up a fake name called Jay Doobie.
That's like a high school thing.
Um,
but he's our editor and he produces with us and um,
you know,
he was,
he's a couple years older than us and he was like a business student who didn't
know anything about movies and wanting to get into film.
And,
and when he first was around us and like interning around us,
I was like,
honestly,
like,
how's this guy going to help me?
You know?
And it was just wrong.
Like he was just brilliant,
sensitive,
smart and amazing.
And if I could go back,
I'd be like,
stop stalking Richard Linklater.
J Doobie is right there.
He,
he wants to be with you guys.
He's brilliant.
He loves you.
He's,
you know,
he's ready to give you everything.
So just dive into that
new experience when,
when you mentioned this click,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
does a social click or you know,
a casual acquaintance translate into a professional click or do you need to work
with them?
Professional setting to see if that's something that will work?
Um,
I have,
I have taken some gambles and I have lost on some of those to be honest with
you.
With some of my collaborators,
like,
Oh man,
we like hang out with we're friends and it's so good and it's working.
And then we get into a work setting and I'm like,
this isn't quite worked out.
Like I thought it would,
you know.
Um,
so I honestly haven't thought as deep about it as,
as you have,
you know,
um,
I don't really know where you're at in your career,
but when I was first starting out,
I almost had,
didn't have as much of that element to be that choosy really.
It was just like,
who's dedicated to me and loves me and on the ninth hour is really going to
stick with me and you know,
who's smart and someone who wants to grow in this field with me.
And that was enough.
Um,
but more often than not,
when I have a good feeling about someone,
you know,
and I meet them,
whether it's just socially and I think we could work together and make good
stuff together,
I'd say nine times out of 10 I'm right about it.
Okay.
Thanks.
Yeah.
If that helps.
Cool.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys for coming.
Appreciate it.